all right baby yes baby welcome back
hey so you had the baby
i did on friday the 13th november 13th
tell me how that went it was really
crazy i had her in a tent
on gladys it all happened so fast i
don't know i was in labor like that
whole night
you had the baby in the tent yeah by
myself i cut her umbilical cord and all
that by myself
i zip tied her umbilical cord and cut it
um it was really crazy somebody called
the ambulance and they made me go to the
hospital
after i but she was fine
yeah i named her zara miracle
i don't know she's it was
it was a blessing and where is she now
she's in a right now she's currently in
a foster care
because they want me to take some like
parenting classes and
some other classes i don't know but
i'm in a program doing that so
and did they test you for drugs uh yeah
she only had weed in her system
remember i was doing i was doing mess in
the beginning and then i
found out you know what i'm saying so i
stopped i stopped really doing mess at
the end
like i didn't want her to have nothing
in her system
so she had weed in her system but they
took her because i guess because i had
her in a tent on gladys
yeah that can't be the best place to
have a child right
well i mean i
i couldn't really help it it was all so
fast but
so it's been like three weeks now it's
been about a month
friday the 13th and you must be missing
her
right yeah it's got to be hard
yeah it is it's crazy she looked just
like me
is there a chance that she might go to
another family
um i mean she's in a foster care but
until
they put me into a more intensive
program they're saying like all i get
right now is six hours
visitation supervised a week
so they want to put me in a like a more
intensive
inpatient program where you can't leave
because at this program i'm not you
could just leave
and go as you want
so you're still living on the street no
i'm in a program
yeah i'm in a program at the coronado
hotel it's basically like a little hotel
room you got a roommate
but it's like a big-ass fun drug house
for kids
like you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want you can leave for 72 hours without
them putting you out
you got to come back once every 72 hours
to check in
looking forward what do you think the
chances are of you doing everything
that's necessary to keep the baby
um well i'm waiting on them to find me
another more
more intensive program but it's on their
time and their calls
i can't i already tried to look for
programs and [ __ ] and they was like yeah
we're gonna find one
that's best suited for you or whatever
so it's all on their time i don't know
i'm hoping that they'll get
that [ __ ] done and you know contact me
back and get me moved but
i don't know because they haven't
contacted me yet and it's been two weeks
do you see your baby every day no i
haven't seen her yet
like they haven't contacted me back to
see her to schedule no appointment they
just called me and told me that i'm
approved for six hour supervised
visitation a week
six hours a week okay
and going through this stress is it
difficult for you
not to use
it is it it's more hard now not to use
than it was when i was pregnant with her
because i don't have her
with me like they're talking about
whenever whenever they move me and they
get me
into the program the more intensive
program that they're
um that i'll be able to get her like and
have her there in my custody all the
time you know what i'm saying
so i'll be able to have her in the
program with me that's what i wanted but
right now they it's a lot harder
it's a lot harder for me not to use
i used the day i got out of the hospital
like
leaving her at the hospital the first
thing i went and did was
and then if you don't get her back
you're much more likely to start using
again right
right if i didn't get her back yet
probably would be
strung the [ __ ] out out here
hmm
all right baby your story is hard it's
hard for me to hear
yeah it's really hard i feel bad for
your baby i feel bad for you
yeah i just hope that
i'll get her back
can your family help in any way no they
won't help me
they won't help you thank you
they won't help you they're they won't
do [ __ ] for me
i can't even call them to talk to like
my little sister i call and talk to her
but she's always working her in school
she takes care of my daughter
i don't know
oh [ __ ] i wish i could just transplant
you to another city
far from skid row man i hate this place
i'm just hoping everything will work out
for the best
at the end they say god does everything
for a reason so
if there's ever a reason to get clean
this would be it
that's what i said that's why i mean
that's why i think i've been so
like strong-minded about it now
been able to do it as as much as i have
all right baby well thank you so much
for giving us the update and uh
i wish you all the luck in the world
thank you hope you get your baby back
thank you and get out of here hell yeah
as soon as i get
her back i'll be gone
all right thank you
you